[Music]
hello everyone this is one is Grand
Master Sabina for sure I'm here at the
San Luis chess club and you are watching
puzzlers paradise so for today I've
prepared a bunch of I'd like to call the
miniatures studies and if we will still
have time then we will go over some
towel games some tile positions tactical
positions but first I would like to
start with some interesting end games
and game studies that have some huge
tactical motifs so we have this position
what do you think about it do you know
it a lot of people if no no ok you're
going to sacrifice it ok so as was the
move wait how do you sacrifice is if you
play look after so you want to say oh
you want to give check and then take the
pawn in each - ok
does everyone agree with that idea or
did you have something else in mind
okay you have sign ok ok
someone was ok
yes so we have two ways of sacrificing
the rook one of them is rook h1 and the
other one is rook f2 king goes somewhere
and then we sacrifice here right so if
we do this we have to calculate and make
sure that by the time we go grab those
two pawns black doesn't make it back to
c8 right so does black make it here
black does make it so that is the reason
why this is one of the first tactical
motifs that was invented in a study and
it was rook sacrifice and you're pretty
much forced to take the rook because if
you move the King for example here what
is what going to do
yes King d3o so you want to try to go
directly yes of course you can do that
if you want to be more tricky you can
play King f1 because eventually black
will have to move away from their pawn
right so King goes here and then they
will lose the pawn so there's no point
for black to try to waste any time so
they take the rook okay so what do we do
now we're yeah yes okay so we have the
choice between King f2 inking f1 right
you're shirking f2 is the one okay and
then can you tell me the line of
tricking f2
very good yes so if everything is forced
and this is the type of position that
you can actually calculate if you want
to but now you have the mate and of
course you want to the kini enough to
not in f1 to allow the promotion with
check ok let's go to the next position
in this position we have a similar theme
right it's a similar theme so what do we
do here with white to win the game
yes bishop where the champagne one King
takes N one King see where he sheet or
c1
okay who says Kings you one who says
King C - no one says King C -
interesting so let's calculate let's
figure out what black is going to do
right so you play King seat which ones
did you say King see one right so
whenever my pawn reaches B - it will be
with check right and then you move your
king and then I will promote right so
you actually play Kings you - very
important you know that matters
let me show you why King c1 is not so
great oops I don't know what I did
Kim c1 b5 right we cannot take em
passant we're going for the
and what do we do now we are in big
trouble because they will promote we
will not lose
or maybe we do lose no because we can
move the king somewhere here and then
when they promote to a queen what do we
do queen h8 King Queen B - if you want
you can do Queen c3 check and then you
can play Queen C - I guess and it should
be a draw right so going back to that
position what do we do here
King C - and what's the final move can
somebody tell me the final move of this
line how will the position end what's
the last move Queen C to mate yes so B 3
we are happy we take it we'll let you
promote the a pawn but then we have the
typical you know mate when the a or H
pawn promotes when we have Queen versus
a pond and mate and obviously like it
didn't matter for us if they promote to
a knight right because Queen versus
Knight is winning ok great let's go to
the next one what do you know about this
position Queen versus rook should be
easy right should be winning for black
right ok
it's way to move though does white by
any chance have any way to draw this
well there's got to be right if I show
the position but but what is the idea
now take a couple of moments and think
about it
okay we have two hands up yes yes
okay so what if so if the King goes on
the e-file we have rookie seven exactly
pinning the Queen draw simple what about
if the Queen King goes to have six Queen
takes us and checkmate
okay yes right so in this position feel
free to give me a lot of checks right so
we have to advance and you still give
checks if I play King of six I think of
okay I'm winning oopsy right
if King h6 now if I go King age six
you cannot give Ruby six check so what
do you do here if I play King age six
yes Luke age seven if I takes time eight
if I don't take and I go here what do we
do yes
okay chicks and I have to sell me there
that's why it's very important I mean I
remember one of the first times I saw
this position I thought okay I need to
be very careful if I ever stay queen
versus rook which has never happened to
me before it doesn't happen so often but
just make sure your King doesn't get
stuck on one side of the board also your
queen should never be as far as I
remember should never be in a knight
position from the king you should always
try to keep it like kind of a little bit
far so when you you try to keep the
opponent's rope pinned oftentimes but
don't bring it too close because that's
the moment where you allow these types
of stale mating ideas so you want to
avoid that what do we think about this
position
what do you know about rook vs. bishop
draw how do you make a draw when we have
a rook versus a bishop in which corner
should we bring our King yes to the
opposite corner of the bishop so that
the bishop can stay and hide I mean help
you hide in the corner okay but here
white has an extra pawn too so it should
make it a little bit easier for them to
have some chances to win or maybe not
can white win this if you would want to
win here with white which move would you
play f7 right so that would be the move
that you would want to know what's going
to happen if you play f7 so what's
what's happening after f7 can we take
the pawn with black yes
king of six and it's over your king is
not in the corner yet right what do you
play here
you cannot take the bishop right now
because it's protected but you're gonna
play this now - then the bishop needs to
move somewhere we have this check and
now just waiting move right and you
haven't made it to the corner if that
would be the corner just imagine fa it
would have been the h8 corner then of
course this is a stalemate right but
it's not the corner so we can just move
and we lose the bishop
so after f7 what is the problem why
can't white play f7 in this position
King g7 you don't need to hurry to take
the pawn immediately after King g7 white
is out of moves and our next move will
be Bishop takes f7 White has no way to
protect the pawn a second time and okay
if you sacrifice it then our King is
close enough to the corner that I will
be able to make a draw for example after
this month how is black making a draw
here yes King g8 you can also play King
e 8 because I cannot follow the the
opposition and try to threaten the mate
exactly so if white wants to play f7 to
win what should i do first
yes
in g6
okay when do we do his back
we should check
and you have to go back so that doesn't
seem to be a progress for white another
idea that white has in this position is
try to chase this Bishop away so we have
to be very careful how we move it where
do we move the bishop now is black
Bishop d3 okay let's say we try to come
like this we should be five
bishop
what is happening now
yeah it looks like what is going to win
Oh Bishop a 6 ok
how is white winning now
rook a7 Bishop c4 check
and now if we play King g7 there's just
King g7 and promote so I think we're
kind of done here with black right so
the only idea that black needs to do
basically in this position is make sure
he keeps his Bishop on this diagonal so
anytime you push f7 I can play Bishop g6
and I also need to make sure that
whenever you want to play King g6 I will
give you a check yes
Bishop f7 can I give you a check
wait let's see you go there
and it's over right
so where do we move the bishop only far
away okay
don't don't put this in f7 okay just
keep it far away and just make sure you
can give the check and unfortunately
right even with the extra pawn cannot
have a way to progress this this is a
draw yes so even with the extra pawn if
you know the right way to do it then
it's going to be it's going to be a drop
so we have the next position it's quite
similar just that now it's really really
important on where you move the bishop
you cannot just move it anywhere let's
see we already have the pawn technically
right on the seventh rank here on second
because we have color switch right and
white hasn't had the chance to move the
King in g2 because blacks King has
gotten control of it before right so now
we already have the pawn there are we
going to be able to win with black hmm
you hope yes I hope so too so let's
think about it what would be the idea
these all kind of have been made in
similar like one after not one after
another but the themes are repeating
themselves in a way in in studies so
someone would come with a theme and then
someone else would try to improve it or
make something beautiful out of it and
some of these positions have become
theoretical positions as well like the
Philidor for example right so yes yes
so let's try to think a little bit in
this position it's actually it's it's
white smooth but first I want to think
about plans here how you want to win
with black so you said King gt4 so you
want to bring your king to f3 and then
just make me right so when you move the
king away from h3 can't I play King g2
or maybe it was black to move here we'll
see in a second
so the idea of black in order to try to
win this is to switch the position of
his rook to get it from the second rank
to the F file first if they managed to
do so then their King is free to move
because your King will not be able to
move to g2 because we will promote do we
agree on that
yes no no it's what it's way to move its
way to move in this position so black is
trying to find a way to get the rook
from second rank to the F file to make
sure you are stuck with your King and f1
agreed so we need to avoid the line for
that to happen because if they make it
then we can't do anything so we need to
make sure that we are able to attack the
pawns so whenever they put the rook on
their file we can capture it so the good
move in this position is Bishop c7 what
happens if we play Bishop d6 ok
play Bishop c5 yes very good king g3 now
we wanted always to be on the GFL why we
wanted G file and naughty file well
first of all because there used to be a
rook there which was restricting us but
also to avoid the checks so now we have
the same position as before right and
it's over for white because check is
coming and you're losing your bishop
what if we play Bishop e5 to control the
F file and make sure you don't get your
rook on the F file what does black do to
win yes rook is six okay and can i play
Bishop d4 yes
okay five if you play rookie sex
Ruki one king takes a you have to play
King g3 and now it's a little bit
different because your rook is not far
away threatening the checks so because
of that I have enough time to just move
my bishop and I'm fine here I can
survive so that's why this is very
beautiful study I think so Bishop c7 is
the only move the idea is as follows if
you play okay seven we have Bishop d6
Fork
so you cannot make it make sense so now
if we want to make it we play Ruby to
where threatening Ruby 7 we're trying to
go on light squares Ruby 7 look f7 so
now what does why do
where does why move the bishop Bishop d6
yes once again if you go to b6 we go
there
you cannot just move the rook randomly
somewhere to bring it on the F file
because we just grabbed the point so we
continue right Bishop e5 again the same
thing so obviously go route de rigueur
here good now let's find a good move for
black to trying to win this yes rookie
to cute move right feel free to take my
rook if you want but it's not so great
for you because now things change right
so obviously you cannot do that so now
the question is where do we move our
Bishop with white you cannot move it on
any square because again remember blacks
idea they want to attack your Bishop and
get on the F file and you might be
losing so where do we move the bishop
yes
Bishop e8 what's the difference if you
move the bishop to be a then if you move
it to d6 for example
okay Bishop d6 increasing
confused so this shall be a tie agree
with you why is this wrong you said
after rook e6 what oopsie
cube you say that if I play rook e6 what
do you do here
that's the move that you play you can
stop it too but Bishop d6 is a mistake
because of something else
not look Seto we had that before right
rook see - we were repeating right Roxy
- Bishop e5 and we're repeating the same
thing
so now black is trying to figure out a
souk slang idea places his rook on a
square and regardless of where you will
move the bishop on the diagonal and I
think it's quite obvious why the bishop
needs to stay on the diagonal to avoid
you from playing King g3 allowing you
from playing in g3 so where does black
move the rook here after which it's over
raagh D - can't I play Bishop e5 and we
have the same position as before I know
right it's tricky
this is a tricky position you win it
with only moves require D - it's only
two already rugby -
why remember before like if you're the
one who plays Bishop c7 here for example
don't we get the thing that we want you
don't white know right what do you do
here
you just move the bishop and then I play
rook have salmon so the line that I had
here is Bishop e5 drug b5 what do we do
now is black I had that move why did I
put that move
kingi drink right this is the line that
we printer I don't know why
who drew calf I've made a mistake
because here black it's not winning
anymore right yeah yeah sorry I had a
wrong wrong line yeah King g3 and we're
running so in this position the only
move that makes a draw is Bishop e8
we're going back to the start because
what's happening if you play this the
very strong move come on take a minute
and try to find it why to move and make
a draw Bishop g3 yes and you've managed
to get your rope to a fate but
unfortunately you've also made many
system yeah and you do not make it in
time to f3 so if you go King G for what
do we do is white
which piece takes finger Bishop Bishop
Bishop takes the rook is on the e-file
when you play King f3 are not
threatening mate so we can just move our
bishop somewhere not not to h4 because
then we would be mated but somewhere
along this where do you move it actually
can't we just play King g1 no we can't
how do we make a draw here yep
actually I should have put one arm of
crazier so that is the way that black is
not able to win so white needs to make
only moves to be able to make a draw
what's happening in this position
you should go for a drawing us so how do
we do this
with white
engage for
can get for King h3
don't give up king f3 king age 2 is
about a good move
well do a play with white here
no one
what's happening the king ugh - so what
is black thread now nothing there's no
threat now right you can't play a -
because we take with check and then you
lose that pawn - so then what do we do
it white here King where you can just
try to approach and he's going to
realize you see I made a mistake so he
will try to probably go back and then
yes you can give check and then go back
but it was important to try to keep him
restricted to the margin so that he
didn't have the opportunity to play -
what do you think about this position
excuse me
you should go for win yes of course so
what's the problem though that you have
here with white black has a past pone
and has a bishop too so how will you be
able to mate or win I mean I guess you
want to mate
let's talk ideas first because the line
afterwards is not maybe as impressive if
you understand the idea it's going to
make it really fun so what do we want to
do here with why to win get the king -
okay so I will just bring my king up to
h4 if you bring your king to H to f7
just bring waking up
it is vitam of yes so don't think moves
yet try to understand the ideas in the
position how can black try to make a
draw not I mean what's his idea to make
a draw it's not try like he actually
wants to do that get rid of the pawn
right so just play f1 whatever piece
promotion and then just push his bishop
in default for example on the diagonal
as long as you don't have yours in e5 of
course but just basically put the bishop
somewhere on on a dark day on a long
diagonal that keeps you from restricting
his King to the margin right to the
corner it's already in the margin to
restrict it to the corner and then you
don't have a way to get around the
bishop so definitely you should not
allow that promotion right
so what's the idea after all I say I
only hear moves I didn't hear that your
idea of course you want to mate but tell
me the idea first how will you do it
because you I want to promote right so
first you blockade right that's Nydia
first you're going to make sure that
pawn is located and also you're going to
make sure you don't allow this Bishop
from g1 to go to h2 right ok so how will
you bring the King blacks King how will
blacks King be forced to go where you
want him to go because you'll only have
a free bishop right and your king
you're not understanding exactly what
they want what I want to say is the fact
that you will actually be able with just
dark square Bishop and your King to
attract this Bishop to wherever you
wanted to go without getting too much
help from your light square bishop
which i think is kind of impressive
because normally i mean you cannot do
that if you just use one bishop no white
is winning here yes especially because
these of these two pieces they're we're
going to use them in a very nice fashion
so we start with check of course so
we're going to try to see what's
happening if he's going in that
direction first that's the thing if you
make move through that temple i can
promote don't forget that yes yes
no now I have a threat right f1 so now
you go back and here I have to decide
what I'm doing right I cannot move my I
cannot promote and I cannot move my
bishops I need to move my king
right let's say go there then now you
give a check and you've brought me where
you wanted to bring me then you go back
I have to go somewhere around eh file
and then we'll go to you f7 so I have
the other line I didn't really put this
so we'll go on the main line here if
black just goes there directly we do the
same right Bishop d6 restricting so now
you're going to try to stay on the H
file okay how do we bring you from there
down to h4 maybe or something like that
yes King f7 q h6
Bishop f4 very good now I think it makes
sense they cannot go King h7 because we
will have a mating - right so we have to
go here
we should be to checking gauge for
mmm-hmm don't forget about your king you
cannot mate with the bishop alone right
bring our king he still remains
restricted and he still pushed down
right what do we do now looks like he
might try to escape King where King you
five and the thing is now if he goes
back we make like a small triangle here
but we keep him restricted so he still
has to go down if in this position he
had gun here why would you what would we
do it white yes just King a five star
mate but wait a second you still have a
bishop that can move right so I think
now it's not a problem to figure out how
you're gonna win that's why black is
going over here okay
what do we do now
last part still important we were able
to bring him all the way from h7 to h4
but still not Bishop G Bishop g2 can I
promote and oh I see what you want to do
right
Bishop g2 can i play king h5
okay maybe this works huh
ah but sorry wait a second I'm confused
you tricked me here what's your threat
I escaped in g3 I almost forgot about
that right I don't need to go to h5 I
can go King g3 right okay so in this
position yes we meet we make a waiting
move Bishop h6 the thing is black has
three moves in this position right he
can play King h5 oopsey can play King h5
him play King g3 or he can exit with his
Bishop finally after such a long time
right if he goes King h5 what's the mate
into that we have Bishop g5 yet that was
your idea I want you to do earlier and
then Bishop e2 and over no way to stop
it what if he goes Bishop h2
come on yes yes
thank you for the bishop right so last
line is to actually go King g3 and now
we're using against this soo-kyung idea
and now
kingi for
what do we do now
maintain three right king each tree or
after
you're said King edge three here that
works too just we need to take this
first and that means I know I thought
this was nice when you realize that you
can actually utilize your your bishop
darts who are bishop only to actually
restrict blacks King this is quite
simple it's think oftentimes you find
yourself in queen and pawn versus queen
and games and you're struggling a lot to
get your pawn to the seventh rank or
promote it but here there's a tactical
idea with which you're going to be able
to win quite fast with white what is
that idea know it's waiting for right
check on a3 King b6
yes that's a small problem that you have
the punished pin no but it needs to stay
that way that blacks Queen cannot move
from there because you'll obviously
promote so how do we make this position
Queen a4 check Queen takes right but I
mean you want that idea but now what's
the I mean you're not going to wind
right right but then there will be Queen
versus Queen right hmm yes so that's
that's losing yeah yeah but why do you
want to sacrifice your queen like if you
sacrifice your queen you need to promote
and then try to get it back so that you
stay with an extra queen right I'm
confused
so you want to play Queen a4 here and
then you want to promote okay what does
black do you're mated right
no daddy you don't want to do that right
yes
you have no okay
queen bee - what is the idea exactly
after queen bee - if I just play King fi
for example yes you definitely need a
wedding move but you need to also
restrict him from playing too many moves
as well Queen before now the king is
restricted so the Queen is the only one
that can move right so regardless of the
square where black Queen moves they're
going to lose let's start with the
easiest one
No
Queen a for King b6 and and
yes
no-no-no
what do we want to do let's think about
that again we want to promote Czech
Queen right when we promote it we want
it to be checked queen so then it's
simple the answer Queen b3 check yeah
check Queen skewer these are my favorite
stuff when that happens it's just like I
can't wait for that like I remember when
I was a kid I was doing these pawns that
you had to calculate when they promoted
and then I was promoting with Czech
Queen here's my favorite sure
so wait back up to the start so you
played Queen before to put blacks King &
Zuke's monk now black needs to maintain
his queen on the diagonal because if he
doesn't you just promote so we just
tried for the moment Queen d5 now the
same thing happens if the queen is in
after it right
check check your King cannot come close
enough like I make sure that there are
at least two squares between the two so
now again we promote and we secure the
Queen right so he can go to g2 as well
but it's not going to make a big
difference because we will just do it in
b2 and quite similar thing will happen
after Queen h1 what will happen here yes
Queen a3
cream bit - and then what do I do if I
go to a six for example or on the a file
you do the same thing and if I try to go
for example to c6 hmm yeah you can make
a green sorry I'll go to c5
this is a nice idea to know I don't know
how many of you have gotten the chance
to play Queen and games with just a pawn
up usually you have more and then you
keep trading and you get through one but
it's a nice idea to know there's another
famous study I think I might have shown
last time I was here with that there was
a pawn in e7 that somehow you're still I
giving some checks and then you're
promoting and were securing but yeah so
here what do we play think we're getting
go king a7 no and then if black plays
this move just what do we do check King
somewhere then we go there
you cannot pin us anymore and your queen
can't just make it to the a file and
then even if it could we can always play
Queen a7 but you can't so when this is
this is quite famous I hope everyone
knows this one this is quite famous yeah
we know it
okay what's the last move I want people
to tell me the last move if you know yes
okay five no that's not the last month
yes
look see one mate okay that's yeah I
guess if you move the rook yes but
what's the move before that then who
said okay yeah King b3 right so this is
the famous position so you push right so
black keeps giving checks you cannot go
over there because then simple drop like
it's quite happy right so what you're
going to try to do is come all the way
down to b3 so when they give you this
check you play king c2 and now you
should be winning because you promote
the next move and they cannot stop the
pot but they have a way to save
themselves which is which one what move
rook d4 so if you promote them to a
queen which a lot of us would really
want to then stalemate so we save
ourselves but white is smart too so they
promote in to up rook they're still
threatening the mate and your only way
to defend that is this move and now the
final move King b3 threatening both rook
and mate and yeah so this is a very
famous everyone should know the reason I
put it here is to remind you of the
ideas so that we can figure out the next
position with white to move do you have
to know that one so that you can have an
idea on how this one might go and here's
someone who didn't say so much today
and if I take the pawn after 95 so you
try to avoid giving up that pawn right
well blacks threat is to take the pawn
right so we only have one move basically
here to avoid keeping up the punch
okay so let's you know well he has to
take right he has to taken this with
check what do we do now
94 and the 94th is also controlling the
square where the rook might go and stop
then you have to take the knight and
what do we play here King c3 room d1 no
the pawn will capture the rook so we got
basically the same position I mean I
should have maybe just shown you this
but I thought I would remind you about
the other idea so now we have the same
as before right you gotta stop the
skewer but you also have to stop the
promotion so then we'll have a rook and
the same thing as before right King b3
next movement I'm not sure we invented
this one and I remember we're really
looking for it and maybe it was from a
game maybe it was from a game but I saw
it quite recently so I thought okay it's
nice it's the exact same idea now this
is something quite interesting to know
how does white draw here it's way to
move why to move and drop it white is
going up yes okay so you're saying that
in this position we play a5 takes takes
what do we do now it black
yeah
King takes a look takes
what do you do no yes
okay
yes quite fun isn't it
you are right you're right about the
idea but you don't trade the rocks that
and here amazingly you have two extra
rocks that you cannot win that's that's
really bad I mean can you imagine
playing this you think you're winning
even if you do it this way you're going
to lose right
and
what it's blacks most threatening mate
so we need to promote in tonight I don't
know what's what's happening here
why would this be a draw or why wouldn't
it be a drawing what's happening rook g7
what's happening now if he goes here
right and you win the night if I go here
just wait
there's no stalemate then ruby 7 king CA
Tru k17 b8 you have to go with the idea
of mate in order to win this when
there's a night at the margin yeah okay
let's do a last position
this also is quite cute and it involves
one or two deals we've already seen
today it is way to move what do you
think is happening here hmm
go for a check draw okay we go for a
drum okay how do we go for a draw
because it seems quite dangerous for
white
what is blacks idea of win just promotes
write quite simple sir Bishop takes c3
and if I just promote okay look at 41
rook f3 interesting
yes
Ruki one
rook takes you through
look at three
what's happening there
not quite sure if you're drawing that
position that is not the solution look a
forest not the solution
Luca for I know it's not the solution I
just played rook c2 rook b2 and then I
want to play it too and then one of
those will promote you think you cannot
stop both right okay so what do we do
last minutes of focus
right so you have two ways to stop the
pump from promoting Luca for Luke h1
right
looking veto
don't give up your ideas yes what's the
final move
they should be - no but okay let's hear
the line row gauge
oh okay I see why you said that okay
sorry sorry okay yes yes you're right if
I play that but basically I have no more
so you can stop here because when I try
to move my rook we take we already have
seen today Bishop versus rook and the
cool stuff about this position is that
again amazing you have a rock in the
pond yet you cannot win because you
haven't managed to bring your king close
enough to protect your pawn and there is
no other way you could have done it
because this opposition is just killing
you if you also had a way to give like
an intermediate check of course you
would have won too but there's no way so
yeah so once again I wanted to show this
line I think after this move I think
this is the reason why it does not work
because I don't see how you can stop it
- no no these pawns come in this
direction oh you can play Bishop h4 then
I really don't know why that's okay then
it's Roxy -
Bishop H for Roxy for I was thinking
rook b2 so that you know whenever I push
it to you cannot take so that I promote
maybe it's Rudy too then one of these
moves has to be the reason why I didn't
check I didn't check that move before
but one of these moves is going to stop
you because I'm threatening check and
then promote and and also e2 okay well I
hope you enjoyed this class and I'll see
you next week same time
[Music]